справа савченка з тесту для євросоюзу
поважають організатори відкритого листа до
європейських лідерів і ви підписали
лауреати нобелівської премії у романській
дівоче наука hispano 20 краєм почету
підписанти враховують на позбавлення заяви
прозваної спокій не так і на конкретній
ідеї
ага. я одягаються на зеленина де
вона будете щетина буду високу просимо
вже в магате в обидві на і звивині брудним
вчинку
прикладом ти можеш тусуватися себе
краще не оминути цього і зняття
санкцій та полку танки
організатори птиці на замовлення
савченко розумію кремль шви години все про
ігнор у та їх не за клік те що чим вона
депутатів європарламенту equites
підписав isover на ньому ось людишки один
інструмент позову листа до верховний
представник єс випробуваю за зовнішньою
політики
ліхтарики магазині chips творить зі списку
з овчинку на кшт old спалах магнітного
а gog.com суворов якщо на завтра
цілий зможемо ж but in a de слони будинку
гаррі не
чому це важливо росія намаяться
проклянуть і санкції європейського союзу та
нашій не ті ти покажи кремлю чим іншим
чому і порушу йому тему савченка на
устілці волосся але наскільки це можливо
звуки + i feel as low as possible
чи українською вчитися 20 місяців війни
волею ж 4 року звела соку і
хлудова не 9 борис не враховуються в
гравець російську суду
у справи савченка